ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and
welcome to another episode
of Android Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And
hi, I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And
in today's episode,
we're going to talk about 10
more navigation anti-patterns.
And when we say 10 more, we
say that because we actually
recorded a previous
episode of the show, where
we went into 10 of the
most common UX issues--
user experience
issues-- that we saw.
And some of those
issues were specifically
related to navigation.
So in this episode,
we'll talk about 10
more navigation anti-patterns
that we've since thought about,
I guess, since that episode.
Nick, do you want to
talk a little bit more
about the background here?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
sorry yeah, of course.
And if you didn't catch
the previous episode,
we went into the
background that part of job
is to work with a
bunch of clients
and look at all kinds of
applications out there.
And we come across all kinds
of issues and variations
on a pattern, some of which
work, some of which don't.
One of the things
we often see is
when people that are new to
Android design, they quickly
pick up things like the
visual language of Android,
but they sometimes
don't completely
internalize the
navigation patterns
and completely grasp
the nuances and some
of the consequences of
deviating from these patterns.
So we wanted to give you the
benefit of all this experience
and highlight some of the
pitfalls we've come across,
and what you should
watch out for
and what you can do instead.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
All right.
Without further ado,
let's get started.
OK, so 10 more
navigation anti-patterns.
The first that we're
going to talk about
is navigation in the
action bar overflow.
So this is getting to
be less and less common,
which is great.
But the idea here
is some of the apps
that we've seen have put
their primary navigation-- so
for example, Home,
Store, My Items,
the different categories,
Browse, things
like that-- basically
the core way to navigate
your app-- they've put this
onto the Action Bar overflow.
And this is really the wrong
place to put your navigation.
There are a number
of reasons for this.
The major reason is that
now most apps don't do this.
Most apps follow the guidelines
and use more standard UI
patterns for exposing
their top level navigation.
We'll obviously
talk about those,
things like the Navigation
Drawer, things like tabs.
But really, this is the
wrong place to put it.
Another reason is actually
on older devices that
don't have the
Action Bar overflow,
it would be hidden
under the Menu button.
And there are lots of
issues with the Menu
button-- the
hardware menu button.
We won't get into
all of them today.
But this is definitely one of
the navigation anti-patterns
that we thought it
was pretty common.
But luckily it's getting
less and less common.
NICK BUTCHER:
Yeah, generally, it
goes against the organization
of having navigation
on the left and
actions on the right
that all the other
apps on the platform
are training users to look for.
So users not finding certain
sections in your apps,
if you find this
pattern, it could
be that they're just
looking for it elsewhere.
ROMAN NURIK: So the second
navigation anti-pattern
that we want to
talk about today is
using UI patterns
in the wrong order,
or having the wrong
navigational hierarchy.
So we have a couple
of major UI patterns
for exposing navigation, things
like the Navigation Drawer
the Action Bar Spinner and
tabs-- action bar tabs,
or just regular tabs.
So there's actually a pretty
strict ordering with how you
should use these-- in which
order you should use them .
And we basically, when you
look at your app in terms
of its informational
hierarchy, you'll
generally create something
like a tree, right?
So at the top, you'll have
Home, at the second level,
you'll have your major sections,
and within each section,
you may have subsections
and subsections and so on.
So one of the things that we've
actually seen a handful of apps
do is use these different
UI patterns to represent
different levels of that
information hierarchy.
Now, the wrong
thing to do would be
to use, say, tabs to represent
the top level, and then
the Action Bar
Spinner to represent,
say, the next level,
and then, for example,
the Navigation
Drawer to represent
the third, or deepest, level.
So this is actually just
the wrong way to do it.
On Android, these three
UI patterns actually
follow pretty rigid level--
or a pretty rigid hierarchy.
So instead of doing
something like this,
the correct hierarchy
would actually
be to always have the
Navigation Drawer represent
the top-most level of your
application hierarchy,
and then, if you have an
Action Bar Spinner, that
should be the second level,
and finally, if you have tabs,
they should be the third level.
Now, if you don't have
a Spinner, if you just
have a Navigation Drawer and
tabs, such as with Google Play
Music-- then it would
just be the Navigation D
Drawer and then tabs.
But really, your
tabs and your Spinner
should never precede the Drawer.
The Drawer always should
represent the top-most level
of the application hierarchy.
NICK BUTCHER: So this is a
somewhat contrived example,
that we have three different
levels of hierarchy--
of navigation hierarchy
in this application.
You probably would generally
want to avoid that.
And perhaps you
might do something
like having two
levels of hierarchy
in your Drawer via a
classical section, which
we'll cover in a section.
But, if you do have that
kind of complex hierarchy,
then do respect this.
You generally want to go
for a top-downward scan.
So the highest level
is a natural mapping
to the root of your navigation.
And one wrinkle,
is, you'll see here,
that the Drawer is obviously
underneath the Action Bar
The difference being that
when you open the Drawer,
Action Bar's expected
to transform.
So in this instance, you would
get only app-wide options.
So in this case,
Spinner would disappear.
You'd probably just have
the application name itself
and any actions not relevant
to the entire application
should disappear from that.
So generally follow
that top-down approach
and you'll be OK.
ROMAN NURIK: And another
thing with the Drawer
is that we did have another
episode specifically
about using the
Navigation Drawer.
And we had, I believe,
Rich Fulcher and Jens Nagel
from the Android
Design team, that
talked a little bit about how
to use the Drawer and in which
cases it's most useful.
So definitely take a
look at that episode
if you have more questions
about using the Drawer.
OK, with that, let's move on.
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
So the next pattern
that we wanted to cover
is talking about tabs.
So tabs in Android have
a very strong mental link
to horizontal swipe.
So whenever you see
tabs, you absolutely
expect to be able
to horizontally
swipe between content.
So for that reason,
if you do have
some kind of
paginated content, you
do want to be careful
about putting that
within tabs, of
because you're going
to have some swipe ambiguity.
When you see tabs, you
expect to be able to swipe
to change between them, not
to move the content within it.
ROMAN NURIK: So one
thing to add here
is that if it's a part
of the tab-- it's maybe
a small section
that's swipe-able--
let's say you have a
horizontally scrolling
photo gallery or
something like that.
If it's a part of the tab,
then it's generally OK.
There are cases where
it's possible to do this.
The issue here is that
the entire tab contents
are another left and
right swipe region.
And so it creates this
ambiguity between,
am I swiping between tabs or
am I swiping between pages?
In cases like if you have a map,
where it's not really swiping
between pages you're, panning
a surface, it's also OK.
But it's, again, something
that you may want to rethink,
because there will
be that ambiguity.
But in this case, this is just
one of those textbook cases
of ambiguity really messing with
the standard Android pattern--
or standard Android interaction
of tabs being directly linked
with their contents.
So instead of doing
this, another way
to solve this issue
is to, instead of
doing horizontal paging, you
can do a vertical scrolling type
thing for the tab contents.
So basically, anytime you have
nested horizontal swiping,
really try to think, is there
a better way to present this?
Maybe it's breaking out the
content into a separate screen.
Maybe it's using a different
interaction-- vertical
scrolling versus
horizontal paging.
But really think about
that, because that
is something that can
create that ambiguity.
So the next anti-pattern
we're going to talk about
is deep or persistent tabs.
These often go hand in hand.
So first, let me
talk about deep tabs.
When we say deep tabs, we
compare deep versus shallow
tabs .
On Android, tabs
should be shallow.
What that means is
that there shouldn't
be too much navigation
within tabs.
Maybe you have a view switch,
like you change the sort order
something, or
something like that.
Or maybe you have
scrolling, and whatever.
But you really
shouldn't have any sort
of hierarchy or
history within the tab.
What that means is,
in this example,
let's say you're looking
at the contents of a tab,
and you select one
of these grid items.
You should take the
user to a new screen.
You shouldn't actually
take the user--
or update the contents of
the tab with the whatever
you just clicked on.
And then when you press
back, it would go back here.
This is not something
you want to do.
This is actually
something we would
call a deep tab, a tab that
has hierarchy or history.
And so the reason for this
is that, first of all,
this is just a platform norm.
This is not something that's
generally done on Android.
But the second
thing is that, what
happens when you
swipe to other tabs
or switch between
different tabs?
You actually leave your tabs
in all sorts of weird states.
And the behavior of what
happens when you get back to tab
isn't really well defined.
Should you reset the tab
back to its top level?
Should you stay where it is?
You really don't want to
have too much state going on.
And really this is
actually a recurring theme.
When your app has too much
state that the user has
to keep in mind,
or too much state
that it's maybe
unexpected to the user,
that's going to
result in confusion.
So these are things
you want to avoid.
And so for that
reason we, generally
consider tabs as
shallow on Android.
Another similar point
here is persistent tabs.
So persistent tabs
are basically tabs
that behave like global
navigation that are always
there throughout your app.
And so the problem
with this-- and they
can either be in the
top or the bottom.
When they're on the bottom
that's even worse because,
again, tabs on Android
should be at the top.
But persistent tabs,
regardless of where they are,
are problematic, because
that's not really
how global navigation
should work on Android.
Especially with things
like the Back button.
What happens when you
switch between tabs
and then do stuff within tabs?
The Back button behavior is
no longer really well defined.
And so it's not really a
platform norm, as well as
there's a lot of confusion
that will result from it
to have tabs that are
persistent across the app.
And for that reason,
one of the reasons
that we created the
Navigation Drawer was
to allow apps to create these
kind of global context switch
type UI patterns, or
UI's, where to switch
between some deep
part of one section
to a whole other
section of the app,
you can use the
Navigation Drawer,
which is available
through an edge swipe.
So really, to summarize this
very long-winded argument,
avoid persistent tabs
that are there throughout,
and avoid deep tabs, basically
tabs that have hierarchy.
Anything to add, Nick,
before we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: You
covered that pretty well.
ROMAN NURIK: OK,
well let's do it.
I'm going to talk about--
actually, real quick--
NICK BUTCHER: This is
what you need to do.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, yes,
yes, that's right.
We had some examples of
ways to mitigate this.
So in this previous
example, you had your tabs
show the contents of the
thing you just clicked on.
In this next example,
instead of showing the tabs,
you basically take the
user to a whole new screen
with a whole new Action Bar
and an Up caret or an Up button
And then to get back to
where the user just was,
they would just
press the Up button.
And then, of course, if you
have a Navigation Drawer,
you can always expose it
here through an edge swipe.
So that's a deep
and persistent tabs.
Nick, do you want to talk about
back traversing across tabs?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
So as Roman was saying about
having these shallow tabs,
we have consider
moving between tabs
to be a very lightweight action.
It's not something that's
going to actually drop history,
as it were, drop something
into your navigation history.
So therefore the Back button
should not unwind your moving
between tabs like this.
So in this example here,
if you're on the third tab
and you were to tap
or swipe between them,
tapping shouldn't unwind you.
In fact, if you embrace the fact
of having to swipe between it,
it would feel pretty unnatural
for a tap of a Back button
to unwind a swipe button.
So that's one of the reasons
why we say not to do that.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
And a similar area where the
Back button shouldn't do, maybe
what you think it
should do, is when
you're changing between
different Drawer sections.
So for the Drawer, you may think
if I switch from section one
to section three
to section four,
pressing Back should
switch between those.
But actually the
platform standard here,
again, for the Back
button, is basically,
when you switch between
sections in the Drawer,
you should actually
reset your task stack.
It's almost like you've
entered in a different app.
And that's really what the
navigation Drawer is good for.
If you look at an example,
like Google+, for example,
the Google+ app, when you switch
between different sections,
you're almost entering
different apps.
And the navigation
Drawer is really
good at these
types of scenarios.
But the guidance here is when
you switch between sections
in the Drawer, pressing
back should probably either
kick you out of the
app, or, if your users
are getting confused by why
is this leaving the app,
it should maybe take you
to the top-most section.
So for example, Home.
So if I go between
Home and Browse
and Search and Store
and Categories,
pressing back from Categories
should really only take me
back Home and then to
the Home screen, or just
the Home screen.
Anything to add, Nick,
before we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: No,
I was just going
to say that's a
really powerful point,
I think, is that if you do
have one natural Home one place
where you should always expect
users to want to come in
on and probably get
back to very easily,
it's OK to have one
level of Back inserted.
It's that fresh task stack to
take them back through that.
So they have that stability
of really easily getting
back to that natural Home
position from a sub section.
But otherwise treat
changing sections similar
this to changing tabs.
It's not going to
have a history in it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Let's move on.
Deep Navigation Drawers.
Do you want to cover
this one, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, the next
one is one of my pet hates.
It's probably a smell, really.
If you're having to
do this pattern here,
of having deep navigation
structures in your Droid,
it probably means
your navigation
needs to be simplified
somewhat and maybe perhaps
broken up into
different sections
or different applications
perhaps, or something
like this.
But the idea of a
Navigation Drawer
is it's a stable list of
navigation targets, which
you can always get to
and jump to and stuff.
And you don't want to put any
cognitive load on the user
to actually remember
where they were
or where they've come through.
And it wants to be a
stable thing that when
I open the Drawer, and I
can have my Home option
or have whatever
option to navigate to.
So you want to avoid
having different steps,
or even seeing secondary
Drawers popping out
from the first Drawer,
which is also pretty crazy.
So do try and avoid this.
An alternative way
of actually having
some kind of subsection
behavior-- and I think
we hinted at this
earlier on-- it
is OK to have these
expandable items.
And the reason
this is kind of OK
is because it's not this
huge content switch.
You're not completely replacing
the contents of the Drawer,
but it's sort of new
and enforcing the users
to keep up with where they
are in their [INAUDIBLE].
But it's just an
in-place expand which
shows the user
slightly more options.
So that is cool.
ROMAN NURIK: And we have
a little bit more guidance
on what the exact
touch target should be,
exactly how they should
behave in the design guide.
So if you go to
developer.android.com/design/pattern/navigation-drawers.hmtl
I think it is, or just search
for Navigation Drawers Android
Design, you'll see some more
details about exactly how they
should behave.
Based each line item should
actually have two touch targets
if section one has its
own landing screen.
But anyway, there's
another alternative.
Nick, do you want to
talk about that one?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
So an alternative
might be instead
of putting all the
navigation in a Drawer,
you might break out to another
[INAUDIBLE] subnavigation.
In this example on
screen here, we're
in the screen you get to
when you switch sections.
You have some more navigation
type activity there as well as
content.
Or, as we talked
about earlier on,
you could combine another
navigation pattern.
So for example, you
might use the Drawer
for your major
navigation sections
and then use a Spinner, perhaps,
for subsections of that.
So don't feel like
just because you're
using a Drawer that you have to
have all your navigation forced
right into that
in the same place.
Think about other ways to
allow subsection navigation.
ROMAN NURIK: And a
good example of that,
again, is Google Play Music.
When you go into--
it's a Drawer-- you
see things like listen now and
then My Library Under My Li
Library you see things like
Artists, G Genres, and so on.
That could have
been in the Drawer,
but that was actually
placed into tabs.
The nice thing about tabs is
that you can actually really
quickly swipe between those
different sub sections.
So definitely think about
different ways to this.
One thing I should mention
here is we specifically
called out content one, content
two in these little wire
frames because you
don't want to just
have purely navigational
elements on here.
You should add a little bit
of content to the screen.
You don't want to turn into
a dashboard type thing, where
you see a bunch of big icons
or a bunch of big text blocks.
And one of the ways
you could do that,
obviously, is to show content.
Another is to just show images.
Show dynamic images
representing that section.
I think an example of that
is Google Play Newsstand.
I don't remember
off the top my head.
But definitely don't just
throw text on the screen.
NICK BUTCHER: And you're
talking about the explore tab
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
All right.
Our eighth item here is
bad Drawer transitions.
So there are a couple
things like this involves.
When we say transition, we
both mean the animation,
the actual visual change, as
well as the transition from one
screen that has a Drawer to
another screen that doesn't.
And actually I think the next
two items are related to this.
Basically, let's say
you open up the Drawer,
and you touch section one,
you shouldn't actually
be taken to a new
screen with an Up caret.
Basically, there's a
strong guidance that says,
any screens that are represented
in the Drawer-- so for example
here, section one, section
two, section three, and so
on-- when you actually
get to the screens
they should also show a
show the Drawer indicator.
So the first issue here
is that you don't actually
see the Drawer indicator, you
see this up caret instead.
So that would be incorrect.
But another slightly more
subtle aspect of this
is the transition.
When you go between section
one and section two ,
you shouldn't see this standard
default zoom up transition that
takes that you see when diving
into content or showing a new
activity, showing a new screen.
You should, first of all, try
to suppress that transition.
So it should be really fluid.
It's almost like,
you touch something,
the Drawer closes,
and then the content
of the section you just selected
just fades in or appears.
It shouldn't be is
jarring kind of zoom up
animation that
changes the Action Bar
and does all this stuff.
Another thing to
think about, more
for developers is-- and
this is a question we
get all the time-- is, should
I have a multiple activity
or multiple fragment app
when I'm using the Drawer?
And there's no easy answer.
There's no right answer.
It really depends
on the situation.
So if you guys have suggestions
for the developers out there,
feel free to comment.
My suggestion would be just
examine the difficulties
and whether or not it
makes sense for your app.
I would think by default
start with multiple activities
with replacing the transition,
but having a single activity
with multiple fragments,
that is possible as well.
OK, should we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think we
just got a good example here.
Just reinforcing the point
that every section which
appears in a Drawer, you'd
expect to have the Drawer as
coordinates showing on the
screen, and for other sections,
it should show you the Up caret.
ROMAN NURIK: So related to that
is never showing the Up caret.
And this is really
view the converse
of that-- or the inverse
of that-- whatever it is.
So like we said, anything that
is represented in the Drawer
should show the
Drawer indicator.
But things that aren't
represented in the Drawer,
for example, here we're looking
at a specific piece of content.
We've now dived into-- or dove
into-- a specific news story,
for example.
At this point the, Drawer
indicator shouldn't be there.
You should instead
show the Up caret,
because you're now in a
deeper section or a deeper
part of the app within one of
the sections in the Drawer.
And so instead of doing
something like this,
you should obviously
show the Up caret.
But what you can do to
still expose the Drawer
is allow an edge swipe.
And again, this is something
that's in our documentation,
in our design guidelines.
You don't necessarily have
to show the three little line
indicator, the Navigation Drawer
indicator, to have a drawer.
In this case, having
the Drawer there
is more like a
power user feature.
For folks that discover
that gesture, great.
For those that don't,
that's not so great.
But they always
have that ability
to navigate to those other
sections by pressing Up.
So you're not really
keeping functionality
from a certain class of users.
You're really just adding
additional functionality
for power users.
NICK BUTCHER: I guess
it's kind of two competing
things, like competing
for the same space.
You want the user to have
that hierarchical navigation,
to have strong sense that it's
going to keep you in the app
and go to a parent type screen.
So you want the Up caret.
And one of the greatest
abilities of the Drawer
is that you can have it
available to you elsewhere
to do these cross-cutting
navigation gestures.
So I advise to resolve
those two competing
things is to show the Up caret,
but allow the edge gesture.
And an interesting
implementation detail
is what do you do
when you [INAUDIBLE]
edge swipe the Drawer open?
I think a really
nice way to do this
is if you take a look at the
way Google Newsstand does
this is they'll
show the Up caret.
And as you that edge swipe
out to open the Drawer,
they'll cross-fade the
caret into the open Drawer
affordance.
So it makes sense that when
you look at the screen,
oh yeah, that's
the Drawer open I
know that touching
that's going to close it.
But when you look at the content
screen, you have that Up.
And it's giving
you that stability,
that expectation of navigation.
ROMAN NURIK: Mhmm.
Exactly.
Should we move on to
our last anti-pattern?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Unit 10.
ROMAN NURIK: Do you want to
talk about this one, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, for sure.
So the last one we're
going to pick out
is using right side navigation.
And we touched on this slightly
at the top of the show.
There's a strong, strong
organizational theme in Android
to have navigation
activities on the left
and actions on the right.
With most left-to-right
languages,
you scan the page in one
way, and it reinforces
the hierarchy, that
this is your navigation,
you're hierarchy,
your top level things.
And the content is going to
be on the right hand side.
So I think on this
example here, we're
showing a tablet, which has a
larger screen available to it,
so [INAUDIBLE] persistently.
So you wouldn't want to put
that on the right hand side.
You'd want to keep
that left-aligned
to go with that general
organization of nav
on the left.
ROMAN NURIK: So basically,
here's the bad screenshot.
Here's the good screenshot.
This really works
with both navigation--
you shouldn't have Navigation
Drawers on the right--
as well as Master
detail scenarios.
You shouldn't have the
Master on the right.
You should really have
the Master on the left.
It should really
read left to right.
And obviously RTL locales,
like if your language
is in Hebrew or Arabic,
this would be flipped.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, So
you've got the gravity start
on Android on the
left and right.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
So those are the 10 more
anti-patterns for navigation
that we wanted to
talk about today.
I guess it's both navigation
and app structure, if you will.
If you have any more
anti-patterns-- well
this obviously wasn't a
comprehensive, exhaustive list.
But if you have any
more anti-patterns
that you want to
share, feel free to let
us know in the comments.
Or just post something to
Google+ with the hashtag
#AndroidDev, and we'll take
a look and possibly comment.
So with that, thanks
again for joining
Android Design in Action.
As always, I'm your
host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And thanks
from me, Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: See
you guys next time.